اخبار العالم ايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم
البانتاجون يعلن اتخاذ اجراءات لحمايه ما
وصف بمناطق حساسه بعد رصده منتضض تجسس
صينيا في الاجواء الامريكيه والخارجيه
الامريكيه تستدعي القائمه بالاعمال
الصينيه وتبلغه خطوره الموقف بجينا تقول
ان المنطاد ذو طبيعه مدنيه ومخصص للرصد
الجوي والبحث العلمي في ختام القمه
الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه في كيا الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتعهد بدعم اوكرانيا في كل خطوه
ضمن مساعيها للانضمام
للتكتلنسكي يقول ان بلاده لن تضيع يوما
واحدا للتقدم نحو الانضمام الى الاتحاد في
الاثناء تتواصل مساعم اوروبيه للتوصل
لاتفاق على مقترح بشان وضع سقف سعري
لمشتقات النفط الروسيه قبل يومين سريان
حظر اوروبي عليها قوى سودانيه تنددها
باستقبال البرهان وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي وتعلن رفضها التطبيع كوهين
يكشف عن توقيع اتفاق السلام بعد تشكيل
حكومه مدنيه ومجلس السياده يقول ان
الطرفين بحثاه تعزيز العلاقات من جهه اخرى
دانت حماس زياره داعيه الخرطوم الى العدول
عن قرارها مبيعات هواتف ايفون تسجل اكبر
انخفاض فصلي منذ عام 2019 لاكثر من 8%
نتيجه اضطراب سلاسل الامدادات المتاثره
بالاغلاق المرتبط بجائحه كورونا في الصين
وتقليص انفاق المستهلكين الى اللقاء